hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dream daddy now we
just got done with our second date with
Craig but we got a lot more daddy to get
through well it's been a long day I'm
just about ready to pack it in after a
few bites of ice cream from the freezer
I turn off all the lights and walk down
the hall to my room I wonder if a man is
still awake that kid needs some sleep as
I passed a room I can hear a faint sound
but can't make sure can't quite make
sure out what it is I get a closer look
is she crying
I knocked gently on the door hey Amanda
the crying immediately stops now right
now voice sounds strained she sniffles I
need to make sure she's okay I opened
the door in the dark I can see a man his
outline in the middle of her bed
he's hugged up against her body is
everything okay I don't want to talk
about it I I just need to know if
something happened did something happen
no nothing happened go away oh I don't
want to press it too hard if she doesn't
want to talk about it then who am I to
really pester all right
something didn't have to happen and
people don't have to start crying just
because something happens something
could be bothering them for a long time
she was almost crying before - alright
I'll leave you be back out of the room
and close the door gently behind me she
immediately starts crying again Wow
I have no idea what has her so upset she
seemed totally normal
I feel awful just leaving her to cry but
I also get the feeling that if I tried
to do anything else it would have only
made her more upset yeah I get that
feeling too you know like I just get I
can't press too hard if someone wants to
be alone like I I can't force my way in
it'll only cause more harm I can't stop
mentally cycling through all sorts of
awful things she could be dealing with
right now more than anything I just want
her to be happy and safe I have a hard
time falling asleep but when I finally
do I'm still thinking about Amanda after
a long night of very little sleep I roll
out of bed and make myself a pot of
coffee Amanda should be up for school
soon maybe she'll be willing to talk
about whatever's bothering her about 10
minutes
before she's supposed to leave Amanda
comes out of a room and makes a beeline
for the freezer morning manda morning
she drops a frozen waffle in the toaster
and slams a freezer door
she won't look at me yikes so anything
big going on at school today no okay do
you need a ride to school no want some
coffee
Amanda pulls the toaster lever up and
takes her still freezer-burned waffle
out before it's finished cooking I have
to go Amanda picks up her bag and
story's out oh okay I haven't seen her
act like this in a long time it's
usually short-lived but it always hurts
hopefully this blows over and things are
back to normal soon I sit back at the
kitchen table and look at a picture of
Amanda and I hanging on the wall in it
I'm teaching her to ride a bike her
faces a mixture of excitement and pure
unbuilt rated fear
I remember how determined she was every
time she would fall off in scrape her
knees she would get back up and try it
again
finally I had to stop her because she
was bleeding everywhere then she started
to cry because she didn't think she
needed bandages and wanted to keep
trying as I put the bike away she just
stood in the middle of the street and
screamed then I took her for ice cream
and it was like nothing even happened
after giving it a bit of thought I
decided that if I force her to talk
about it I'm only gonna make things
worse but I have an idea I start
rummaging around for ingredients I hear
a man to walk in the door instead of
heading for the kitchen like she usually
does she makes a beeline to a room she's
clearly trying to avoid me hey pumpkin
what can you come here for a second
there's a moment of silence yeah I want
to say sorry about last night I'm just
worried about you kiddo I get scared
when I know something's wrong and I get
even more scared when I feel like I
can't do anything about it
dad I so just whatever it is and you
don't have to tell me if you don't want
to whatever it is just know that you
have a dad in your corner who wants you
to be happy
mm-hmm you know I'm bad with words so I
was hoping I could speak a language we
both understand I pulled a cake out of
the refrigerator and place it on the
table
hopefully this frosting is set by now
dad it took me a really long time
because I ran out of red frosting
somewhere around sad and had to start
over sorry you're sad but I support you
100% right
this is
beautiful it's strawberry Amanda gives
me a big old hug I grab some plates and
forks and service up some delicious cake
so it's really stupid what is this whole
thing I know I've been really weird
lately and there's just I don't even
know how to explain it I feel like I
might have to make you a charm I'm
listening
do you want me to take notes oh I guess
I should start from the top so you know
how Mr is going to the fancy art school
in California right Mr what's the
difference between Mr and Mrs what you
did the best friend the other one I'm
gonna go with I think Emma are came
first the best friend you got it yeah
Wow proud of you anyways ever since she
got the acceptance letter I've been
feeling like she's drifting away you
know and she's been spending a lot more
time with Grayson Emma P just thought it
was all in my head for a while but then
I found out from Rosie M that both of
the MS Grayson Noah all went to a party
in McKenzie F's on the same night they'd
all told me they were busy studying for
the calc a B final yes I do need a chart
so another important piece of
information is god this is embarrassing
I have that's the thing what whoa I had
no idea definitely didn't know that okay
that is a total mystery to me I I
couldn't have pieced that together from
any of the information I had previously
you're a bad liar so yo I learned from
the worst anyway so the only person I
told about the crush was Mr and she
promised not to tell anybody
I didn't confront them about the party
thing because they didn't want to start
drama so I just keep quiet and keep
going about my business Amanda sighs and
then one day I invite everybody you have
to get notches at the mall and after not
texting me back for like two hours even
though none of them ever put their
phones down for more than 30 60 seconds
they all say they're busy like
simultaneously so I tell them never mind
I'll just eat nachos at home right but
we were out of chips and I really want
to run nachos totally understandable so
I go the ball anyway I get the food
court who do I see there for a selfie
mr.and no all hanging out together and
eat nachos without me why it gets better
I'm standing by the escalators watching
them and I realize that Noah has his arm
around Emma or which is kind
weird right but then they kiss no yes I
know so I stole over there and I'm alike
hi grace drops a nacho on her shirt
because of course she does and mor just
glares at me grace grace I don't know
who that is
grace is duh well yeah but that's not
the important part
yes I think that's a passing acceptable
answer grace is the one nobody really
likes or I guess that's me now but
anyway nobody will say anything and I'm
just like you guys suck which I realize
it's not the most eloquent thing safe
but I was very angry and really
embarrassed and I just wanted to get out
there so I left without nachos my dad
which only further contributed to this
shitty day and immediately drafted a
super long text to the group chat asking
him why I've been so weird they've been
so weird and I wrote another one mor
asking how long the Noah thing's been
going on sorry no that's a lot you still
following oh my god what mr saye Oh mor
you know what let let me just read it to
you
Amanda pulls out a phone to read word
for word and arduous really long string
attack messages can you believe that I
cannot I cannot believe I care so much
about Amanda's social life and
well-being but man do I not understand
what she's talking about is all beyond
me and I'm trying my hardest to be
support their dating in secret for like
months so I told her that she's been
really terrible friend she's like well
if you think I'm so terrible then just
stop being my friend and I was like okay
and then she left me on red and then
wait with me on red what's that oh like
she saw my message and didn't reply and
I know because there are read receipts I
don't know what read receipts are but
I'm just gonna nod and pretend like I
know what I understand gotcha so while
this is all happening I talked to him
appeared about how mad I am because
she's always been kind of reasonable and
I'm bending it to her about how pissed I
am oh ah but ever I don't text me is
like how could you say that about me and
I'm like say what about you and he tells
me the name apiece and screenshots of
everything I told her to the group chat
that I got kicked out of alright I think
you lost me up screenshot but that
definitely sounds bad so much more our
blood
honestly it's all just really stupid
teenager stuff the bottom line is that
everybody dropped me half my grade hates
me
and now I have no friends I'm so sorry I
almost expected it from everybody else
but my arse been there since dad died I
can't believe she would just stab me in
the back like that
I'm not even that mad that she's dating
no I'm just upset that she lied to me
about it for so long
Amanda stabs at the remnants of her cake
okay get back I'm kind of mad she's
dating Noah like what did I do wrong why
did everybody just decide I'm not cool
anymore
why wasn't I enough I don't understand
and as mad as I am at everybody like I
miss them dad Amanda looks so dejected I
almost can't take it what could I
possibly say to them anyway that's it
that's all sordid tale thanks for
listening tune in next week for more hot
Goss Wow
I know it's pretty dumb see it's not
dumb at all
you just gotta alienated by your group
of friends like for no reason just
because people can't talk about their
feelings it's not no it's a stupid thing
to be upset over no Amanda your feelings
are real don't ever be mad at yourself
for having feelings I guess unless you
secretly been a robot who's been
approximating human feelings this whole
time dad if I was a robot I would have
transformed into a monster truck a long
long time ago seriously I know you
probably don't want advice but I feel
like it's my duty as a dad to bestow
upon you a few nuggets of fatherly
wisdom here it comes
I'm ready let's see high school sucks
yeah it's pretty much the bottom line of
everything high school just sucks it
just plain-old does but it's not forever
high school sucks
honey high school sucks you make friends
with people just because they're there
when you're living in your hometown
there's a pretty small pool of people to
choose from but once you're out of that
you get to choose who's in your life you
get to choose who you surround yourself
with but once you go to college and once
you get out into the real world you're
gonna be exposed to all sorts of people
and it's gonna be easier to make friends
with people who really get you some of
those friendships can last a lifetime
I mean look at me and Craig and some of
them only last a little while and that's
okay you're gonna make so many awesome
new friends at the art school ultimately
I think this says
about their character than it does about
yours because you're amazing and if they
can't see that well that's their problem
I'll keep that in mind I look down at
the table did we just eat that whole
cake yeah we did just eat the whole cake
well good talk I gotta go run this off
Amanda gets up to go to her room before
she closes the door she turns around hey
pops yes thank you you're always welcome
dad that sucks oh we got high school
relationship drama oh it's always the
worst people drop people out of friend
groups at the drop of a hat you don't
think about the repercussions of it and
also people don't talk about their
goddamn feelings Oh
why is everything gotta be lies and
subterfuge man teenagers are the most
incredible Liars in the entire world
okay all right hey Craig hey Craig i'ma
say hey Craig how are you doing Craig
man if I got oh you know what they say
about third dates things get pretty
serious are you sure this is your dream
daddy oh I'm afraid of what god I would
have to date every single dad wouldn't I
wouldn't I have to date every single dad
oh boy oh god but I haven't do I go for
the completionist route but I kind of
want to see what it leads to right now
then I'll have a more educated guess of
what's gonna come in the future at least
finish off this one path and then I can
always go back to the save I just saved
right probably maybe I doubt that son to
present true but I'm it took some time
for our schedules to line up but I was
finally able to find a weekend where
Craig and I could go camping he always
say so busy with working the kids but
it's good to know that we'll be able to
spend some time relaxing together in
nature since our first run up man to go
on a regular runs with Craig I mostly do
them because it only seems like the only
time we get to
but the added benefit is that I've seen
a lot of improvement in my health I was
able to sift through the Attic and find
my old camping gear from college Greg
put me in charge of bringing the
sleeping bags in the tent while you
takes care of the food so I double check
to make sure everything is ready to go
Craig should be here any minute now a
man is gonna be spending this weekend on
a school trip to our nation's capital
she hasn't been away from home without
me for longer than a day since she was
14 hope she isn't feeling as nervous
about it as I am
she's probably excited sitting on top of
her luggage in order to get it finally
zip hey pops ready for your trip once I
get this bad boy all zipped up I'm good
to go
whoa how much did you pack that seems
like a lot for two days oh it's all my
camera equipment lenses tripod flash all
that are you gonna even have time to
take pictures I'll find a way I need to
get some good shots from a series on
national monuments what's the serious
about internet series where I reimagine
Disney Princesses its founding fathers
I'm kidding nobody likes taking
portraits of my friends oh I'm gonna be
in the woods out there in nature you
know roughing it just me and cracking
mother nature the old Mod the red dead
trees out there we'll be able to text or
call you at all I know it'll be a
nightmare you're not being able to hear
from me well it's all right I'll be able
to survive a couple days without
constant updates on who just got voted
off the International haunted house
hunters and for the record push down a
flight of ornate stairs by a ghost
really beautiful stairs manifest zipping
up the big suitcase and looks into the
next door the four-bedroom she was
writing gives you a big hug relax I'm a
big kid now I can take care of myself
papa runo besides I got share a room
with Monica Sanders and two moms
chaperones the most trouble I could
possibly get into is falling asleep in a
tub of ice cream on me oh well all right
don't steal anything okay since you
asked nicely fine promise step outside
haul my bag buy me Craig's already
strapped some camping gear on top of my
modest foot stylish car he notices me
carrying my equipment and hurries over
to take it from me
is it no don't you don't you oh don't
you dare
Craig kaan can you keep those hands to
yourself remember it's your weekend to
relax
take it easy I guess I can't argue with
that everything's good with Amanda yep
on her way to a school trip to
Washington DC what about your offspring
already in Spanish lease for the weekend
I'm ready to get my camp on I love the
rest of my stuff at the Craig Scarn we
get in Oh No what's wrong I think I left
my juicer plug in we gotta go back are
you worried that somebody's gonna break
into your house and cold-press some
carrots no it's just I just try to relax
man let the juicer float away take all
your fries have blend them into pulpy
good vibes
Craig Dave said deep breath do we have
anything to listen to well I haven't my
place is a series of CDs a guide you
through one a thorough and intense Cal
genex workout oh yeah
Shaun T's the best do you want to listen
to those ah car calisthenics just
kidding
yeah Greg and me a thick case filled
with CDs take your pick
thumb through page after page of kids
sing-along CDs oh yeah twinkle twinkle
little star takes me back way way back
keep going I give through the end of
Gason fine in the very last slot a blank
CD with Craig's handwriting on it DJ keg
stands mix volume one made it just for
the trip I think you'll like it
I popped the CD into the car stereo and
it's immediately I'm transported to her
old dorm room hit after hit plays it's
you know if we're both happily screams
singing the lyrics to each song as we
fly down the highway the song was Carl's
favorite Carl the third roommate he
brought the dog home one night and I
couldn't cry you two apart so we spent
an entire semester fabricating a story
about a foreign exchange student
roommate who had a really bad cough that
sounded exactly like a dog's bark and
then we had a room inspection that RA
was so suspicious of us but could never
prove anything
Carl was just under a blanket bless that
pups courage under fire man we did some
dumb things back in college the arse
flybys we belt out tunes and whatever
non-existent key our voices register and
soon enough we were surrounded by lush
trees and spectacular vistas if
everything amazing the nature
it feels good to be back out here bro
real good we park our car at the
entrance to a familiar trail load up our
gear on our backs I'm thankful that I've
been working on the health over the past
couple weeks otherwise I've been
dreading all the hiking that's about to
happen Craig looks intently as his phone
everything all right yep just had to
fire off one last work here babe Craig
pock to the phone when we start off the
on the trail it's relatively easy but I
know I would have been huffing and
puffing at this point if we weren't all
for all the murder Sprint's I take a
look around me and taking all the tall
trees and animal chirps everything okay
back there is ill reception
oh yeah being out in the middle of
nowhere will do that I recognize the
looking anxiety on Craig's face what if
there's a problem let's see the
perception is the least of our worries
what about the Bears there's a lot of
bears here see you've trained for this
all that survival wilderness training
look Craig we all know that if you
really wanted to flex your calf muscles
and fly out there like a rocket ship all
the way back to Maple Bay you're gonna
be fine we're gonna be fine this is our
weekend keep marching down the trail but
it seems like Craig is still worried
after everybody stops in his tracks
maybe we should go back you can find
another campground that gets good phone
cell reception
Craig seriously what's wrong I mean just
really nervous
my dad instinct is kicking in and my
mind keeps conjuring up all sorts of
worst-case scenarios what are something
happens to the girls I don't have a
signal you have no way of knowing let me
tell you that feeling never goes away no
matter how old your kids are you just
got to remind yourself that they're in
good hands good doesn't say anything I
give them a reassuring punch on
trying to remember why we came out here
the plan was to get away from the goal
and just focus on ourselves for this
little trip no distractions no cell
service just to dad's relaxing out in
the woods Craig looks at me directly and
be honest no distractions no cell phone
service just two dad's relaxing outdoors
we're gonna have some fun this weekend
Greg and I get back to marching it's not
too long of a hike before we get to the
campsite we're both glad to see the
world and all the people there can't
believe you still have this tent
found a to my attic and already checked
it for holes it seemed better bit days
sure but I think we'll be able to
survive
I dumped the bag of fabric and poles on
the ground we unfold the tent in the
desired spot I am Craig the steaks we
still know how to do this right of
course we do we do not after 20 minutes
is struggling like people in a bad
infomercial we somehow managed to build
an upright structure that closely
resembles what a tent would look like if
you ask somebody to draw a picture with
one roof shot
I wouldn't put this up against the storm
but I think we'll be able to survive the
night we set out a couple of chairs in
our cooking equipment admiring our
handiwork bro look at this go looking
upon the kingdom we have built upon this
rock we shall grill our meats and drink
our bruised for we hold dominion over
this land verily and look at our camping
chairs which we are going to sit upon so
what's next on our camp Stravaganza
docket well now that we have shelter
settled I think it's an for us to do
some exploring there's a waterfall a
little bit up the way but sure we liked
let's get hiking then Greg and I venture
into the woods we amble along taking our
time to chat and admire the
Brent reaches out in arm and stops dude
that look like what I think it looks
like look over to where he's pointed Oh
God
it does it does look like that thing the
thing that we all know that it looks
like the thing that we remember that it
looks like from so long ago that tree
looks like I can't get over how detailed
it is examine the bun tree further the
contours bourbon it even has back
difference I thought we were gonna have
a great time camping but this makes it
even better Greg holds back up snicker I
aspired to have everything it's good
it's this one
I'm snickering to now let us analyze
this tree further Rick and I share a
huge belly laugh at our awful jokes the
best thing about this is that there's no
daughters but here's a joke gifs are bad
well I think everybody out there is
there to tell you your jokes are bad
almost as bad as mine I'll get there if
I ever get to dad hood we high-five
we're so cool Greg and I hit the trail
again it's been a long time since we've
been out here but everything seems more
or less familiar we point out old
landmarks that we remember back from our
college days I think we're getting close
down check it out it's clearing up and
as we get it closer I can hear water I'm
resting over he'll go skinny dipping
[Music]
Craig and I agreed to by a wide clearing
surrounded by trees in front of us is a
beautiful waterfall spilling into a
large body of water that runs into a
river mouths a gape with the genuine
beauty of the place we go to investigate
the old waterfall just bud gorgeous bro
nature's so rad
peering further we get an idea of how
deep the pool is I think we could jump
off of it like the old days there's old
dad here is happy on dry land looks like
you could climb right up over there we
didn't even bring swinging river trunks
oh no whatever will we do
what are you talking about Craig
immediately begins taking his clothes
off look at Craig's but I can't help us
sneak a peek at that that is one good
quick turns around suddenly he catches
me look I do a lot of glute work except
for hell major gluts in the running you
know all the murders friends you know
they glued it up every day all day every
day
I immediately turn away blushing and I
ignore the fact that there were
eggplants shooting out of his butt
coming in what oh I don't know about
this dude he's already making his way
over to the waterfall by the time I
finished my sentence when he realizes
I'm not right behind him he turns around
and rolls his eyes we together for years
and I've seen your ass more times than I
can count
it's no big deal I can count me let's
put on a show
who needs pants anyway our way of
addressing this who needs pants anyway
the society's oppressed I agree
down with pants down with the system
that's the spirit take my shirt off and
drop it in a pile with Greg's clothes I
put the rest of my clothes on the ground
feeling naked Craig and I climb up on
the top of the waterfall making sure not
to slip on any wet rocks he reaches the
people for I do and offers me a hand
getting up at the top we look over the
cliff and in at the tiny lake it seems
so much higher from this perspective
greg has always been a daredevil he
pulled some stunts and calls that I'm
honestly still shocked he survived I was
always the one standing on the sidelines
watching and hoping I wouldn't bring him
home on a gurney man this could be
dangerous Craig looks me in the eyes
don't think just jump jump into love
Craig candy balls off the waterfall and
into the lake creating a huge splash I'm
worried for a moment before we finally
resurfaces from under the water whoa he
dreads water and looks up at me you
counter what bro don't think just jump
how are you supposed to just not think
I'm pretty sure that's not physically
possible my toes grip the edge of the
rock the water looks so far away don't
thing just run off the edge trying to
move my best cannonball somewhere in the
middle it turns into a really graceful
belly flop ow
I hit the water with a loud slap I
resurfaced to find Craig giggling I read
that belly flop a solid eight out of ten
your form was lacking but your heart was
in the right place I believe believe
splash water at Craig haha are you sure
about that i splashed up again you've
given me no choice Craig splashed me in
the face with a huge wave of water
you've wakened the baby he launches
another wave of water at me don't you
put me in a corner here they'll put a
wild animal in the corner I'm wild I'm
going over the corner let's see
hammerfist dunk him squirt water head up
with your hands well that's not very
Duncan hammer fist
oh is that like bloom yeah hammer fist
oh my god Duncan hammer fist with the
force of thunder I bring my fist down
into the water creating a tidal wave
that drenches Craig good one bro
but I think I can do better Craig
answers back with his own tidal wave
it's big enough to launch me back he's
soaked craig truce please Craig thinks
about him yeah sure we shake hands
this piece man the jump was such an
adrenaline rush not so scary now huh
I'll race you to the top I'm gonna race
Craig to the top we run all the way up
to slick rocks and cannonball off the
water again what a rush
good for him on that one want to go
again with the same energy we had in our
youth would climb back up on top of the
waterfall I'm brave enough to try flip
which I'm sure looks incredibly graceful
as I belly flop into the water whoo man
this is fun got one more in you takes a
little more time but we get to the
waterfall and both do our best running
jumps into the water below all right I
think that's my limit we should get back
before it gets too dark all right bro
you sure it's my time to jump I scurry
up the rock once more and do a classic
cannibal wow this is so fun get it kind
of cold want to go back to cam now all
right all right okay we should probably
head back all right
our clothes on knows that they're
soaking wet maybe it's last late wasn't
the best idea that's okay we'll get a
fire going in no time we can dry off and
get some dinner going sopping wet we
hike back to the camp and unpack
everything we need for dinner Craig
pulls out a couple steaks and some
chopped potatoes in tinfoil you ready
for the feast a man takes see the Craig
train is pulling into the relaxation
station and I'm your conductor that's so
sexy let me cook for it absolutely not
cooking is the thing that relaxes me the
most I'll take it from here
cooks now I remember his entire
sophomore your diet consists of
microwavable mac and cheese but not
microwave trouble believing the thing
you just said at least let me start the
fire let me start the fire sure let me
just grab my matches Craig reaches into
his backpack rummages around his back
pulling things out and checking every
pocket oh I know I packed it Kraig
checks another bag and still can't find
it my stomach grumbles now I'm more
acutely aware of how cold and wet I am
we really need to get a fire started
okay well it's not the end of the world
so stupid because sworn I packed it
sorry dude
don't be we can figure this out I can
start a fire we're smart guys I mean our
kid
be plenty of survival programs on the TV
of a naked reality star can do it so can
we need some wood I just adjusted the
tree surrounds no shortage of that and
some tinder make that work
and I think some ancient aliens are then
supposed to come by and give us advanced
technology or renovate our house depends
on the show breaking I gather a variety
of wood bark and moss until we have all
the materials we could find conceptually
make a passable looking campfire just
that fire right that's a fun part sound
ascetic now and cool breeze rustles the
leaves of the trees around us we have to
work quick I've done this in the past
and I know I can figure it out just give
me a second any way any way I can help
give me some moral support lift my
spirits to make this fire happen I got
that yeah okay all right go overboard
I'm gonna go overboard that's what I
that's how I roll I over board you
really give him that final breath yes
you're an amazing hard-working father
with a steady work ethic and everybody
loves you you're a superhero the
neighborhood dad's respect you immensely
we'll see your pot looks great
oh stop you make me cry okay okay go on
your tears putting out the fire
eventually Craig is miraculously able to
get something going he blows on the
embers and gently places the glowing
moss into the base of the pit soon
enough we have a nice little fire going
way to go man a regular old outdoorsy
fellas hooray for not dying bro succeed
one of the lawn chairs Craig brought and
cozy up to the fire warming up my hands
relax man take it easy
let me handle dinner now watch as Craig
Stokes the fire and sets up a makeshift
grill for the steaks if I just read the
slower gets a lot more sensual and for
all that hiking and swimming in
fire-starting
I'm able to relax a bit with the sound
of crickets in the scent of steak fill
in the air I actually feel pretty calm
Craig expertly Sears two steaks in a pan
he's been heating up on the fire
cracking time and crushed ginger over it
while blasting him off in butter
Wow I didn't know he was actually good
at cooking the fanciest I ever saw him
get in college was when he started
sprinkling the seasoning packet onto dry
ramen and eating it up straight this
happened you cereal every morning with
beer instead of milk I grew up I guess I
think these are just about ready push
the state on steaks on a paper plate and
sets them aside I start to reach for one
but Craig smacks my hand away dude let
them rest it'll be more flavorful that
way patiently I noticed that smooth jazz
in the background I can hear that I hear
that I hear that I patiently return to
my seat eyeing the steaks longingly from
a distance they smell incredible
Craig prepares a side salad for us in
the meantime sprinkling feta cheese onto
root freshly chopped greens
he played sit next to a generous pile of
roasted potatoes covered in olive oil
and rosemary
once it's all ready we sit down by the
fire and dig in everything tastes okay
bro I already know it tastes good I'm
salivating just at the fine that's what
I'd like to hear
remember how for an entire semester we
would eat burritos for breakfast lunch
and dinner it's so hard not to go back
to that look at you now man you have
kids a great job a great ass and now you
cook like a vengeful wizard whose
arch-nemesis in microwavable food I'm
really impressed by how much you've
gotten your life together
Craig laughs but there's no humor in it
I'm glad you think that bro I glanced at
Craig while he picked up his salad you
real grew out of his baby face but
something about his expression that
makes him seem so much older than he is
a sense of maturity he didn't have in
college he looks exhausted you okay oh
yeah come on I don't need for long
enough to see when you're down I don't
know I'm tired bro
I think being out here is making me
realize this out drained I feel you work
really hard Greg it can't be ma'am I
have to for my girls I volunteer at
their school that cook them healthy
meals for them I do everything I can
make sure they're safe and happy and
when they're with their mom I'm always
working overtime so I can support them
then you work out a lot so you can crush
anyone who stands in their way
hi that and I don't want to fall into my
old habit
I need to set a good example for my
girls everything I do is for them and I
wouldn't have it any other way but it
seems like it's bleeding you dry nice if
that's what it takes to raise him well
then it's worth it
Greg buddy I know your where you coming
from here but you gotta take care of
yourself too
I do though I eat right and exercising
that's not what I mean man you're too
little butter on too much toast you know
do you get that I could be more butter
for yous what I'm saying your toast is
so big it means my butter do you get me
cragger
you get me one you're spreading yourself
too thin life's needs balance it's great
that you care this much about your kids
but can't neglect your own needs because
you're too busy taking care of everybody
else you matter to I don't know it's
just I know I can provide for my family
and if I take a step back and look at
everything objectively I know I'm doing
right by that I don't know but I can't
explain it man there's always that voice
in the back of my head telling me I need
more to do more it's like it's never
enough for me every time I try to relax
that voice keeps telling me I don't
deserve it to be honest I feel even feel
guilty being out god damn it I just
realized I just realized I'm dating
Craig cuz he's me ah [ __ ] ah I have a
great ass and I'm not enough butter for
my big honking toast god damn it I'm
cried Greg you're trying your best and
you're doing an amazing job that's a
fact
but even if you weren't you would still
deserve happiness man do I though bro
is there some significant difference
between the two of these super
suspicious oh there we go look at Craig
and think about what a good friend and
even better father he is he's
compassionate he's hard-working
he's relentlessly positive he encourages
everyone to be the best version of
themselves he makes me want to be a
better person if you could only see
yourself the way I see you
Craig beams he gets up and walks over to
his supplies come on
I brought the dessert are you gonna use
the campfire to tour stops in some grand
boubou though I know a little nothing
about cooking Craig pulls out
marshmallows
well you still know how to make the
s'mores right I think the more important
question is do I know how to make
s'mores
do you know how to make s'mores as I
recall usage is completely black in the
marshmallows
I stand by that it's charred on the
outside but gooey and center's preserved
brutish quick throws the marshmallows at
me and I catch it in my mouth oh we used
to be able to do that at a greater
distance against the winning
disadvantage give me a week of practice
and I'll be competitive again Greg and I
sit in the warm glow the campfire
watching embers float up towards the sky
the stars are so much brighter out of
here yeah mm-hmm I miss this mark me too
we stay here until it gets late half
remembering stories from college we
watch as the fire dies and eventually
clamber into the tent we're crawling to
the ten nine four all mice
[Music]
i unfurl my sleeping bag wait where's
the other sleeping bag I look around for
a second oh no if we only brought one I
musta left in it oh ho home oops
it's all yours dude I'm sorry I'll just
curl up over here in the cold no way
here
Craig unzips is sleeping back and
spreads it out so there's enough room
for both of us to a job of it
hey bro good night bro roll over and we
face away from each other without a
blanket just really cold and shiver
without realizing I find myself nestling
closer to Craig I'm sure he wouldn't
mind it turns over I feel its breath on
my neck
it started to focus on anything else I
turned over trying to get more
comfortable I opened my eyes to find
Craig's face is only a few inches from
my own for once he looks at peace
his eyes flutter open his hand finds a
place on my waist
not sure who leans in first but suddenly
we're kissing we look at each other
again my heart racing Greg oh man I got
strong feelings for you bro feelings I
can't deny anymore bro
[Music]
I rub my hand sir his hair the down his
chest
Craig brings me closer wrapping his arms
around me I feel so bro secure nothing
not gonna make a bro fun after that one
Brooke here I feel so
[Music]
[ __ ] you know talking about old times
is fun but oh I like making new memories
with you god that's cheesy I don't care
I smile tracing the lines of his hip
with my finger we kiss again I'm not
worried about us getting too cold I
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
don't know what any of these scores mean
but I keep getting ranked s which i
think is great
my total seems a lot higher than my
points seemed to suggest
did it though nailed it okay alright so
anyway I don't know if that's gonna end
the game after that but I'm gonna pause
it here because obviously I want to play
this more god I love it
I'll probably make longer episodes later
on because it would it would take
forever if I just go deeper for dad so
I'll probably just try to try to do
longer episodes for more of it but I had
I love this game so much thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you think of this down the
comments below let me know what the the
Craig path is and and obviously there
are there are so many endings to this
obviously you could have gonna have like
bad dates and whatnot and I know there's
just so much exploring happening in the
game so let me know what you think and
let me know what I should do next but
I'm probably not gonna listen
just follow my heart
that's what this games all about so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]